rosetta è una missione pazzesca e ve lo
dico sinceramente raccontare la storia
del suo viaggio è come entrare in un
film di fantascienza ma anche raccontare
di persone vere in carne ed ossa persone
vengono da tutte le parti dell'europa e
si trovano insieme come gruppo lavorano
per creare un sogno incredibile
io ho avuto la fortuna di accompagnare e
gran parte di questo viaggio e insieme
agli amici del centro di controllo della
missione quindi vorrei raccontarvene
qualche episodio il mio contributo
personale a rosetta inizio nell'anno
2000 inizia a lavorare ad halmstad che
per chi non lo sapesse è gemellata con
brescia quindi mi sembra una coincidenza
piuttosto fortunata e il primo giorno di
lavoro mi venne messo in mano il manuale
dei sistemi dei rivestiti di sistema del
software per controllare il satellite
rosetta prima cosa
studiamo cos'è rosetta rosetta è una
missione che deve studiare una cometa
questa cometa è lontanissima ci metterà
dieci anni di viaggio 7 miliardi di
chilometri poi arriverà la commette ci
farà atterrare sopra un lander io
comincio a guardarmi intorno perché ero
convinto che fosse uno scherzo detto
questo è uno scherzo ai miei colleghi
vogliono vedere come reagisco di fronte
a questa storia non c'era nessuna
telecamera non era una candid camera era
veramente lo scopo di questa missione è
una cosa bellissima e che dopo tanti
anni adesso sono qui a raccontarvi di
qualcosa che ha prodotto della scienza
fantastica
quindi siamo partiti con l'idea che era
fantascienza ci troviamo con delle cose
veramente
bellissime il 2000 è stato
importantissimo perché sono cambiate
tante cose ma una cosa su tutte è
cambiata la definizione di rosetta per
tutta la mia vita fino a quel momento e
immagino per qualcuno di voi anche il
rossetto è sempre stata solo questa
questo è vero che da quel momento e
immagino fino alla fine dei miei giorni
rosetta invece ad essere tutt'altra cosa
rosetta è un satellite bellissimo a dei
pannelli solari enormi giganteschi 64
metri quadrati di superficie un'antenna
gigantesca che serve per comunicare con
la terra queste distanze incredibili
nello spazio profondo e attaccato su uno
dei suoi lati cioè file il lander che
appunto scenderà sulla cometa
iniziamo il nostro viaggio e rosetta sta
nella punta di questo raggio che vedete
questa è un'area file
il razzo più potente dell'esa i raggi
vengono lanciati da kourou nella guyana
francese
in quel momento noi nelle soc ad
halmstad siamo seduti in consolle e
siamo perfettamente impotenti perché
tutto dipende dal rehab dall'area file
se tutto va bene
il satellite entrò nella sua orbita
iniziale e da lì poi comincerà una
sequenza automatica aprirà i suoi
pannelli solari si metterà in contatto
con la terra e noi cominciamo a guidare
ma in questi momenti voi immaginate la
tensione di persone che hanno lavorato
anni e anni e anni e tutto dipende dal
successo di questo momento quindi la
nostra concentrazione nello sperare che
semplicemente tutto vada bene per darci
poi il nostro lavoro
questo è l'inizio di un viaggio
incredibile quello che vi voglio
mostrare è un'animazione che ci porta
all'interno di questo viaggio che è
durato dieci anni voi guardate la terra
ogni volta che la terra su un giro
intorno al sole
e passato un anno evidentemente la
traiettoria bianca è la traiettoria di
rosetta all'interno del nostro sistema
solare
questo viaggio è durato dieci anni e
come detto ha percorso miliardi di
chilometri non saremmo mai riusciti ad
arrivare fino alla cometa se non
avessimo usato un trucco per cercare di
aumentare l'energia di rosetta questo
trucco consiste nel passare vicino a dei
pianeti e sfruttare la loro attrazione
gravitazionale quindi rubare loro un po
di energia per essere scaraventati in
orbite sempre più grandi abbiamo fatto
tre volte con la terra e l'abbiamo fatto
una volta con marte potete guardare
dalla dalla grafica come ogni volta
l'ordine di rossetta diventa sempre più
grande se avessimo dovuto fare queste
operazioni soltanto col propellente non
ci saremo
riusciti sarebbero stati necessari
decine di tonnellate di propellente che
evidentemente non è possibile guardate
dopo l'ultimo passaggio intorno alla
terra
questo è schizzato rosetta in un'orbita
grandissima che va a congiungersi con
quella che poi che sarà quella finale
quella della cometa
adesso prosecco è talmente lontana dal
sole che anche con i suoi enormi
pannelli solari non ha più la capacità
di avere abbastanza energia per mandare
avanti tutti i suoi strumenti quindi
inizia la cosiddetta fase di ibernazione
voi pensate in questo momento tutto
viene spento tutti gli strumenti e
sistemi di comunicazione
rimane in piedi soltanto un sistema che
permette al propellente di non
congelarsi e una sveglia una sveglia che
è pronta per suonare due anni e mezzo
dopo
quindi ci troviamo adesso abbiamo fatto
un salto temporale siamo nella sala di
controllo dell'est con questo è posto da
cui si controlla rosetta sono passati
due anni e mezzo a noi non sapevamo
nulla di rosetta abbiamo preso delle
antenne grandissime una di 70 metri in
america è un'altra di 35 metri in
australia quindi una della nasa e una
dell'esa e li abbiamo puntate nello
spazio nella posizione in cui noi
credevamo che rosetta sarebbe stata dopo
tutto questo tempo o immaginate abbiamo
dovuto predire la l'orbita di rosetta
per due anni e mezzo
questi sono i segnali che vengono dalle
due antenne diverse e quello che stiamo
aspettando da un picco in questo show lo
scoppio che mostri appunto un segnale
ricevuto da uno è probabilmente da tutte
e due le stazioni il problema è che il
segnale non è arrivato al punto in cui
noi ce lo aspettavamo e non è arrivato
dopo un quarto d'ora e dopo mezz'ora non
c'era ancora nessun segnale
e lì veramente quasi tutti abbiamo
cominciato ad avere una sensazione molto
brutta e voi immaginate anni e anni di
lavoro anni di volo se adesso lo sette
nazioni sveglia è finito tutto non
abbiamo più un lavoro non abbiamo più
uno scopo abbiamo speso anni di energie
e stavamo pensando già a cosa dire alla
stampa c'era la stampa di tutto il mondo
versavano pensando a cosa fare
e quando ormai veramente sembrava che
fosse tutto perso il segnale è arrivato
vedete che comincia questo picco
all'interno del ii ciclo scopi e quando
c'è stata la certezza voi potete
guardare l'esplosione di sollievo e come
passare dall'inferno al paradiso enna è
successo pure questa volta confesso è
venuta la pelle d'oca e questo questo
video l'ho visto cento volte 200 volte
ogni volta che lo vedo non vengono i
brividi perché questa è l'espressione
del sentimento di un gruppo che ha
vissuto insieme per così tanto tempo non
servono soltanto dei matematici dei
fisici degli ingegneri per fare queste
cose
servono delle persone che lavorano
insieme per me il fattore umano in un
gruppo è una componente fondamentale ed
è quello che ha portato queste persone
durante gli anni a capirsi a passare i
momenti difficoltà a passare sopra le
difficoltà personali anche le ambizioni
personali con l'idea di portare avanti
questo progetto una cosa complicatissima
che soltanto scomponendola in blocchi
ognuno avendo una responsabilità e
parlando insieme agli altri è riuscita a
arrivare a questo risultato io sono
veramente onorato di aver fatto parte di
questo gruppo nella prima parte della
missione
non dimentichiamoci che questa non è la
fine della missione queste all'inizio
quello che abbiamo adesso infatti è che
rosetta comincia a fare una grandissima
frenata e arriva a vedere la cometa e
quello che vediamo è una cosa che più o
meno è quello che ci aspettiamo la
cometa per noi è sempre stata
rappresentata come un oggetto più o meno
sferico bitorzoluto è invece quello che
abbiamo trovato è una cosa completamente
diversa
le prime immagini ci hanno dato uno
shock
questa è una una struttura del tutto
inaspettata
ci aspettavamo una patata e ci
ritroviamo una scamorza spaziale che è
lì e che gira e questo ha provocato
delle reazioni incredibili gli
scienziati erano alle stelle
questo è il fantastico mai avremmo
trovato una cosa così bella
gli ingegneri della dinamica del volo
erano
le mani nei capelli noi dobbiamo entrare
in orbita intorno a questo oggetto e ci
dobbiamo fare atterrare sopra un lander
è una cosa di una complessità
incredibile quindi ci sono state
discussioni ci sono stati moltissimi
scelte da fare ma la cosa più importante
era riuscire ad arrivare vicino a questa
cometa
immaginate che la cometa ha
un'attrazione gravitazionale 100 mila
volte più piccola di quella della terra
quindi non si può parlare di una vera e
propria orbita intorno alla cometa fino
a quando non siamo abbastanza vicini e
non conosciamo come è fatta questa
cometa non conosciamo la sua massa la
sua distribuzione
quindi gli ingegneri della dinamica del
volo di danse hanno inventato queste
traiettorie piramidali sono dei lati di
100 chilometri più o meno di lunghezza
scendendo sempre più verso la cometa
osservando la traiettoria di rosetta la
sua modificazione da parte della seppur
piccola gravità della cometa ha aiutato
a capire quale fosse la sua struttura
quale fosse la sua massa e quindi a
cercare di raffinare sempre di più i
cambi di traiettoria per poter scendere
sempre più vicino quindi è stata una
fase importantissima in cui si studiava
la cometa e si cercava di capire come
avvicinarsi sempre di più
arrivati a distanze più piccole quindi
intorno ai 30 km circa
voi immaginate che siamo a centinaia di
milioni di chilometri dalla terra
la commedia e circa 3 km e stiamo
entrando in orbite circolari di 30 di
più o meno di 30 km di raggio
a questo punto diventa possibile avere
delle orbite che blair ian e come quelle
dei satelliti intorno alla terra quindi
se noi non la giochiamo rimane lì è più
o meno certo con delle approssimazioni
molto grandi fa delle orbite circolari
siamo scesi fino a 10 km per cercare di
mappare benissimo e prendere foto di
tutta quanta la cometa per decidere dove
far scendere il nostro amico file molto
importante questa fase come dicevo prima
perché c'erano dei desideri contrastanti
gli scienziati volevano andare in certi
punti particolari tipicamente i più
difficili da raggiungere e che
tipicamente quelli in cui
l'illuminazione il contatto radio con
rosetta sarebbero stati più complicati
immaginate che il lander non parla con
la terra ma deve mandare segnali a
rosetta che l'intorno gira e rosetta poi
li manda sulla terra
comunque siamo arrivati al momento più
secondo me una cosa fantastica nel
novembre del 2016 inizia la fase di
atterraggio
rosetta si mette in direzione di
collisione con la cometa e lascia il
lander
questa è una foto fatta dal lander da
file verso l'alto quindi vedete rosetta
la spacecraft madre che sta lì sopra
e questa è una foto dei suoi grandi
pannelli solari e la foto successivo è
ancora più bella perché è una foto fatta
da rosetta allender che ha tirato fuori
le sue tre le gambe di atterraggio e sta
scendendo verso la cometa foto
successive ci fanno vedere appunto il
lander che ha iniziato andare verso la
cometa e questa è l'ultima foto non so
se vedete il puntino bianco dei lander
che si sta avvicinando
ci sono volute sette ore per coprire 22
chilometri di distanza dal punto del
rilascio fino al contatto quindi
immaginate una velocità di circa 50
centimetri al secondo all'inizio come
una persona che cammina ma qui passiamo
alle foto direttamente dal lander questa
vedete una delle due una delle tre gambe
di fila e questa è una distanza molto
ravvicinata e vedere la testa della
cometa e qui ci siamo quasi questa e 40
metri dalla superficie notate questa
pietra che si vede in alto a destra
perché ci servirà dopo per capire dove
atterrato file e adesso
preparatevi alla storia questa è la
prima immagine della superficie di una
cometa direttamente da un oggetto
depositato lì non era mai successo nella
storia dello spazio e questa è
un'immagine che rimarrà per sempre in
tutti i libri di storia dello spazio una
cosa di cui siamo tutti veramente
orgogliosi è stata una delle più grandi
conquiste del nostro lavoro
questa invece secondo me è l'apoteosi
della matematica dell'uomo dell'ingegno
il punto in cui il lander doveva
atterrare era distante dal punto in cui
effettivamente atterrato di meno di 120
metri
stiamo parlando di una distanza di 500
milioni di chilometri dalla terra su una
cometa di tre chilometri che gira su se
stessa conferire 12 ore questo è una
cosa che mi lascia sempre a bocca aperta
il mio rispetto per i colleghi amici
della dinamica del volo è una cosa
veramente che mi porto
sempre peggio cosa è successo
file ha toccato terra esattamente nel
punto in cui l'uomo ma non c'è rimasto
nel cerchietto blu vedete le orme delle
zampe di fila che purtroppo è rimbalzato
e se ne volato via
guardate nel cerchietto rosso a destra
quella e file l'ultima immagine di file
mentre sta volando via i sistemi per
ancorare la terra non hanno funzionato
siamo stati sfortunati no siamo stati
fortunatissimi perché file è rimbalzata
un'altra volta sulla cometa e si è
fermato in un punto che all'interno di
quelle liste rosse che vedete ma è stata
una fortuna grandissima perché con
quella piccolissima gravità fila avrebbe
potuto rimbalzare e tornarsene nello
spazio nella sua missione sarebbe finita
lì
rosetta ha cercato comunque nel tempo
sempre di andare a vedere di trovarlo
era volevamo avere una prova del punto
in cui fosse atterrato e finalmente a
poche settimane prima della fine della
missione siamo riusciti anche a trovarlo
vedete nella parte in basso a destra c'è
un ingrandimento e si vede file
incastrato in quel crepaccio dal quale
ha fatto tutta la sua missione di
scienza pro7 ovviamente ha continuato la
sua missione durante due anni torna la
cometa e ha raccolto una quantità di
scienza spettacolare delle foto
incredibili e alla fine della missione è
stato deciso di farla atterrare anche
lei sulla cometa e quindi queste che
vedete sono le ultime immagini di
rosetta che scende piano piano verso la
cometa abbiamo continuato a raccogliere
scienza fino all'ultimo momento e quindi
vedete alla fine si avvicina in questa
parte di ombra fino a quando siamo
arrivati al contatto tutti gli strumenti
sono stati spenti rosetta non manderà
mai più segnali e momento in cui si
dovrebbe urlare di gioia ma vi confesso
che la gran parte delle persone al
centro di controllo aveva come una sorta
di gruppo lavora dopo tutti questi anni
vedere il segnale che scende diventa
piatto è una cosa veramente forte ma
questo mi porta però a introdurvi
l'altro punto fondamentale del mio
discorso e volevo farvi notare che
nessuna di queste nazioni è riuscito a
mandare rosetta sulla cometa nella
francia nell'italia nella spagna è stato
l'insieme di queste nazioni che ha
creato un sistema capace di fare questa
cosa incredibile lesa e
l'agenzia spaziale europea mette insieme
22 stati membri e attraverso tutti i
contributi attraverso le migliori
personalità dello spazio dell'ingegneria
della scienza è riuscito a fare questa
cosa incredibile
voi pensate che poche decine di anni fa
al centro della nostra europa fra
francesi fra tedeschi fra italiani fra
inglesi ci ammazza ma decine di milioni
io penso che il cambio sia bellissimo
adesso le stesse nazioni stanno lì e
insieme fanno dei progetti spaziali
incredibili e le due componenti del
fattore umano e della cooperazione
internazionale
secondo me è quello che dovete portarmi
via da questa presentazione e per
farvelo rimanere ancora meglio in testa
solo un esempio molto personale che
riassume le due cose
questo è il giardino di casa nostra mia
moglie spagnola
io sono italiano i nostri bimbi sono
nati in germania quindi hanno tre
nazionalità e parlano correntemente come
madre lingua l'italiano e lo spagnolo e
tedesco
e quando la gente mi chiede ma voi come
vi sentite vi sentite più italiani più
spagnoli e loro sono le spalle di combo
parlano in differimento
indifferentemente le tre lingue io
stesso dopo 20 anni in germania non
posso dire di sentirmi al cento per
cento italiani è però non mi sentirò mai
al 100 per cento tedesco quindi per me
c'è questa opportunità bellissima e di
legno sono europeo
questa per me è una è una cosa
bellissima e io auguro ai miei figli e
ai vostri figli di avere la possibilità
di vivere di crescere di lavorare di
imparare in un'europa in cui le diverse
nazioni capiscano e continuino ad
approfittare delle loro diversità per
creare insieme qualcosa di eccezionale
ed incredibile come è stata la missione
di rosetta perché io credo che ne
abbiamo veramente bisogno di questo tipo
di cooperazione
[Applauso]